>>> IF YOU'VE SEEN MY COMMENTS
ABOUT FOX NEWS IN THE PAST, YOU
ARE WELL AWARE OF THE NICKNAME
I'VE GIVEN THE NETWORK.
IT'S THE BULLFACTORY, BUT MAYBE
IT SHOULD BE THE BULL SHO VICKS.
JUDGING BY HOW THE NETWORK SPEWS
PRO-PUTIN PROPAGANDA.
>> WHY IS IT DISLOYAL TO SIDE
WITH RUSSIA BUT LOYAL TO SIDE
WITH UKRAINE.
THEY'RE BOTH FOREIGN COUNTRIES
THAT DON'T CARE ANYTHING ABOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
KIND OF STRANGE.
IMAGINE IF MEXICO FELL UNDER THE
DIRECT MILITARY CONTROL OF
CHINA.
WE WOULD SEE THAT AS A THREAT,
OF COURSE.
THERE WOULD BE NO REASON FOR
THAT.
THAT'S HOW RUSSIA VIEWS NATO
CONTROL OF UKRAINE, WHY WOULDN'T
THEY.
WE DON'T GET ANYTHING OUT OF
PUSHING UKRAINE INTO NATO, SO
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
>> YOU SHOULD HEAR HOW CONRAD
TUCKER SOUNDS WHEN HE'S
TRANSLATED INTO RUSSIAN, AS IN
RUSSIAN STATE TELEVISION.
THEY'RE EATING IT UP LIKE A BOWL
FULL OF BORSCHT, POINTING TO
WHAT HE'S BEEN SAYING FOR
MONTHS.
APPARENTLY THE SAME GOES FOR
VIEWERS OF TRUMP STATE TV, AND
THAT IS FOX, OF COURSE.
TOM MALINOWSKI SAYS HIS OFFICE
IS GETTING CALLS FROM FOLKS WHO
SAY THEY WATCH TUCKER CARLSON
AND ARE UPSET WE'RE NOT SIDING
WITH RUSSIA.
TUCKER HAS EVEN LAUGHED AT THE
IDEA THAT THE U.S. WOULD DEFEND
UKRAINE MILITARILY.
>> FRINGE HAS SENT THIS TWEET,
QUOTE, HAVING LOST IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE GRAVEYARD OF
EMPIRES, THE REGIMES NEXT
MILITARY ADVENTURE, INVADING
RUSSIA IN WINTER.
PERFECT.
>> YEAH, NOT SURE WHY HE'S
LAUGHING.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
LAWMAKERS FROM BOTH PARTIES, AS
WELL AS FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS,
HAVE LONG SAID THAT PUTIN'S
CHIEF OBJECTIVE IS TO
RECONSTITUTE THE SOVIET UNION.
SOUND FARFETCHED?
LAST DECEMBER REUTERS REPORTED
THAT RUSSIAN STATE TV HAD AIRED
SOME PROVOCATIVE COMMENTS FROM A
DOCUMENTARY "RUSSIA: NEW
HISTORY."
IN THAT DOCUMENTARY, PUTIN
LAMENTED THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION, SAYING IT WAS A
DISINTEGRATION OF THE HISTORICAL
RUSSIA UNDER THE NAME OF SOVIET
UNION.
WE TURNED INTO A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
AND WHAT HAD BEEN BUILT UP OVER
1,000 YEARS WAS LARGELY LOST.
YET FOR MONTHS DURING THE
ESCALATING TENSIONS BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE, TUCKER HAS
BEEN QUESTIONING BY THE U.S.
DOESN'T SIDE WITH THE KREMLIN.
>> WHY WOULD WE TAKE UKRAINE'S
SIDE AND NOT RUSSIA'S SIDE.
SINCERE QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE
AMERICAN PERSPECTIVE -- BUT WHY?
WHO'S GOT THE ENERGY RESERVES?
WHO'S THE MAJOR PLAYER IN WORLD
AFFAIRS?
WHO'S THE POTENTIAL
COUNTERBALANCE AGAINST CHINA,
WHICH IS THE ACTUAL THREAT?
WHY WOULD WE TAKE UKRAINE'S
SIDE?
WHY DON'T WE HAVE RUSSIA'S SIDE?
I'M TOTALLY CONFUSED.
>> CLEARLY.
UKRAINE IS A DEMOCRACY.
RUSSIA IS AN AUTHORITARIAN
REGIME THAT IS SEEKING TO IMPOSE
ITS WILL ON A VALIDLY ELECTED
DEMOCRACY IN UKRAINE.
WE'RE ON THE SIDE OF DEMOCRACY.
>> YEAH, I'M FOR DEMOCRACY IN
OTHER COUNTRIES, I GUESS.
>> THAT WAS OHIO REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MIKE TURNER TAKING
TUCKER TO SCHOOL, SAYING THE
U.S. STANDS UP AGAINST DICTATORS
WHO WANT TO EXPAND THEIR BORDERS
BY FORCE BECAUSE WE'RE THE GOOD
GUYS.
NOW SURE PUTIN IS MORE CZAR THAN
COMMUNIST, HE MAY BE THE
OLIGARCHS OLIGARCH.
BUT DON'T FORGET THE RUSSIANS
JAIL -- LAST SEPTEMBER A
EUROPEAN HUMAN RIGHTS COURT
FOUND THE KREMLIN RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE 2006 POISONING OF A
FORMER RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL WHO DEFECTED TO THE
WEST.
SO, TUCKER IS CLEARLY STANDING
ON THE SIDE OF A DANGEROUS
AUTOCRAT WITH DELUSIONS OF
GRANDEUR.
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE TUCKER CAN
RELATE TO THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE TUCKER SEEMS TO
HAVE A THING FOR AUTOCRATS, A
STRONG MAN FETISH.
LATELY HE'S BEEN FIXATED ON
HUNGARY AND VICTOR WAR BONN.
LAST YEAR TUCKER AIRED HIS SHOW
FROM HUNGARY, AND NOW HE'S BACK
WITH AN INTERVIEW WITH ORBAN,
WHO MAKES CLEAR HIS DISDAIN FOR
MIGRANTS COMING INTO HIS
COUNTRY.
>> BIRTHRATES ARE DECLINING.
THAT'S TRUE IN THIS COUNTRY AS
WELL.
IT'S TRUE IN EUROPE.
THE POPULATIONS ARE LITERALLY
DISAPPEARING.
MOST GOVERNMENTS IGNORE THIS
TREND OR IMPORT MORE CITIZENS
FROM THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> WE WOULD NOT LIKE TO LEAVE
THIS COUNTRY TO THE MIGRANTS.
THIS COUNTRY TO THE MIGRANTS,
ORBAN SAID.
SOUNDS FAMILIAR IF YOU WATCH
TUCKER'S SHOW AND ALL OF HIS
SEGMENTS DEMONIZING IMMIGRANTS
AS, QUOTE, MAKING THE U.S.
DIRTIER.
NEVER MIND THE FACT THAT THIS
NATION WAS BUILT BY IMMIGRANTS
AND THAT OUR TRADITIONAL
NATIONAL MOTTO IS E PLURIBUS E
NUMB, OUT OF MANY ONE.
HE IS PLAYING DIVIDE AND CONQUER
FOR RATINGS.
THE BIGGEST EXAMPLE OF THAT MAY
BE CLOSER TO HOME AND THE COVID
PANDEMIC.
ON ALMOST A NIGHTLY BASIS,
TUCKER BRINGS ON GUESTS WHO
PEDDLE ANTIVACCINE NON-SENSE,
LIKE THIS SEGMENT THAT AIRED
LAST NIGHT.
>> THESE mRNA COVID VACCINES
NEED TO BE WITHDRAWN FROM THE
MARKET NOW.
NO ONE SHOULD GET THEM.
NO ONE SHOULD GET BOOSTED.
NO ONE SHOULD GET DOUBLE
BOOSTED.
THEY ARE A DANGEROUS AND
INEFFECTIVE PRODUCT AT THIS
POINT AGAINST OMICRON.
DESPITE THAT THEY MAKE YOUR BODY
MAKE THAT YOU THEN PRODUCE
ANTIBODIES TO IS NOT THE OMICRON
SPIKE.
>> TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR, WHAT HE
IS SAYING IS ABSOLUTE GARBAGE.
NO PUSHBACK FROM TUCKER.
THESE VACCINES HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO BE SAFE AND HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
AND JUST AS TUCKER AND THE
BOLSHEVIK FACTORY ARE ACTING AS
A MOUTH PIECE FOR PUTIN, THEY
ARE DOING SOMETHING PERHAPS EVEN
MORE DESTRUCTIVE.
WITH THE U.S. APPROACHING 1
MILLION DEATHS FROM COVID, FOX
AND THE PEOPLE ULTIMATELY IN
CHARGE THERE, THE MURDOCK
FAMILY, ARE INFLAMING A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS.
TO THE MURDOCKS, IT'S YOUR
NETWORK.
YOU OWN THIS.
YOU OWN TUCKER'S PROGRAM THAT'S
PUTTING OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
IN PERIL, PUTTING OUR HOSPITALS
IN PERIL, PUTTING ALL OF US IN
PERIL FOR RATINGS, FOR MONEY, SO
THESE AMERICAN OLIGARCHS CAN
KE